[Música]
rusia dijo que ya terminó la primera
etapa de su operación militar en ucrania
ahora las tropas del kremlin se
enfocarán en tomar el control de la
región separatista del donbass ucrania
respondió que no ceder a su territorio
según la organización de naciones unidas
en la asediada ciudad de mariupol la
cifra de víctimas civiles y la dimensión
de los daños en infraestructuras dan
cuenta de que se ha violado el derecho
internacional humanitario y que se han
cometido crímenes de guerra
presentando un frente unido contra rusia
la unión europea aprobó una medida para
intentar mejorar sus suministros de
energía en la cumbre en bruselas los
líderes acordaron comprar gas de manera
completa
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
estar con ustedes y comenzamos esta
emisión hablando de que rusia cambió su
estrategia de guerra en ucrania y es que
ahora se va a enfocar en objetivos más
limitados luego de que se cumplió un mes
de la invasión y no ha logrado doblegar
a las fuerzas ucranianas moscú anunció
que su primera fase de la operación
militar ya terminó y agregó que ahora se
centrarán en liberar a la región
separatista del donbass según el
ministerio de defensa del kremlin los
separatistas pro rusos controlan el 93
por ciento de lugansk y el 54 por ciento
de donges ante todo esto el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski respondió
que si está abierto a negociar con rusia
pero no a ceder su territorio
la conversación debe ser seria la
soberanía ucraniana debe ser garantizada
la integridad del territorio ucraniano
debe ser garantizado las condiciones
tienen que ser justas
más temprano hablamos con luis alberto
villamarín coronel retreat retirado del
ejército colombiano él nos explicó si el
anuncio de rusia es el fin de la guerra
o no en ucrania no significa eso al
contrario eso es un paso más que está
dando el señor útil para avanzar en su
proyecto de engañar al mundo y de
conseguir el dominio de ucrania como es
parte de su propósito de un gran nivel
comenzamos porque es que nunca ha dicho
claro cuáles son sus objetivos y en una
misma semana cuando anuncia que va a
utilizar armas nucleares contra
quien le lleve la contraria en la misma
semana que en la madrugada de hoy hace
unos bombardeos contra varias ciudades y
sigue destruyendo las capitales y que
anuncia que podría utilizar hasta armas
químicas es imposible creerle y que
nunca he dicho la verdad entonces ni
tiene los objetivos claros ni ha dicho
la verdad ni tampoco podría regresar las
tropas a rusia con las manos desocupadas
y con nada que mostrar porque le podría
costar el puesto y hasta la vida
no es lo que está buscando si lo
hicieras y el donbass es ir paseando las
zonas de ataque ir colocando primero el
donbass luego avanzando hacia otros
sectores y buscar
que a largo plazo conquistar toda
ucrania es decir es como más bien un
replanteamiento de su objetivo pero no
un retiro y mientras las fuerzas rusas
informan que dan por terminada la
primera etapa de su ofensiva militar los
soldados ucranianos avanzan en una
contraofensiva en varias zonas del país
les contamos todos los detalles en el
siguiente informe
la calma regresó pero en el paisaje
están todavía las heridas de los
violentos combates este pueblo a unos 50
kilómetros al occidente de kiev estaba
ocupado por las tropas rusas al inicio
de semana los rusos retrocedieron
después de la contraofensiva ucraniana
de los últimos días
de 42 creo que más temprano que tarde
todas las tropas que llegaron van a
retirarse aterrorizadas porque el señor
está con nosotros cuando hay extraños
por 30 kilómetros al norte la misma
escena
mccann y volvió a estar bajo control
ucraniano en las calles se ven los
tanques rusos destruidos esta ciudad
estratégica situada sobre la autopista
que lleva a la capital vídeo semanas de
bombardeos y de combates intensos
no cabe duda que los rusos querían
cortar todas nuestras vías de
comunicación busqué subgrupos wouter
naciones con los soldados rusos todavía
se encuentran en los alrededores de la
ciudad así como en moción también
retomada por el ejército ucraniano y el
pin y boat chat se encuentran todavía
bajo intensos combates pero el
ministerio de defensa británico asegura
el miércoles que los soldados rusos
están muy cerca de ser rodeados la
contraofensiva se lleva también a cabo
al este de kiev
los rusos parecen tener problemas de
reabastecimiento en este frente a las
tropas de moscú habrían retrocedido unos
35 kilómetros en los últimos días la
oficina de derechos humanos de la onu
denunció que en ucrania se ha violado el
derecho internacional humanitario y se
han cometido crímenes de guerra en medio
del conflicto los civiles se llevan la
peor parte con millones de refugiados
víctimas mortales la crisis alimentaria
en las ciudades atacadas rafael pérez
nos trae más detalles
fosas comunes violaciones al derecho
internacional y crisis humanitaria este
es el panorama con el que los organismos
de derechos humanos de la onu describen
la situación en ucrania
si miramos mariupol claramente el número
de muertes y víctimas civiles allí es
significantemente mayor estamos tratando
de investigar la escala por ejemplo
hemos podido obtener información por
satélite sobre una fosa común estimamos
que una de esas fosas tiene alrededor de
200 personas
los asaltos y bombardeos indiscriminados
de las fuerzas rusas a las ciudades
ucranianas dejan una huella de crímenes
de guerra según la onu
la magnitud de las bajas civiles y la
destrucción de bienes de carácter civil
y sugiere claramente que se han violado
los principios de distinción de
proporcionalidad la regla de las
precauciones factibles y la prohibición
de ataques indiscriminados
también se conoció sobre las
desapariciones forzadas y las
detenciones arbitrarias de funcionarios
locales se han documentado unas 22
principalmente en las áreas ocupadas por
rusia se supo además que la crisis se
extienda el tema alimentario el 45 por
ciento de los ucranianos están
preocupados por encontrar comida y se
están reduciendo la cantidad de comidas
que consumen los adultos están
sacrificando sus comidas para que los
niños tenga algo que comer en este
sentido la agencia de naciones unidas
para los refugiados dio a conocer que en
ucrania más de 10 millones de personas
han visto su vida en peligro unos 1000
35 civiles han muerto y al menos
1650 han resultado heridos
entretanto en bruselas acabó el segundo
día de la cumbre de líderes de la unión
europea el debate se concentró en como
el bloque puede frenar el alza de los
precios de la energía ante la invasión
rusa y ucrania el presidente francés
emmanuel majón afirmó que la comisión
europea ya tiene en sus manos un plan
para comprar gas de manera conjunta uno
de los países que podría suplir
parcialmente la falta de suministro es
eeuu
además el mandatario rechazó la idea de
rusia de cobrar el gas en rublos la
moneda local esto fue lo que dijo el
presidente francés
todos los textos firmados son claros
está prohibido a los europeos que
compren gas y que estén en suelo europeo
deben hacerlo en euros
así que no es posible voy a hacerlo como
rusia solicita y no es contractual
actual
el mandatario estadounidense joe biden
visitó una localidad que ha acogido a
cientos de refugiados en la frontera
polaca con ucrania desde la ciudad
polaca de primicia nuestra corresponsal
pilar cebrián no reportaba más temprano
los detalles de esta visita y la
importancia de la región
si badén ha estado unas pocas horas en
esta ciudad del sur de polonia a unos 80
km de la frontera ha llegado hasta aquí
hasta una localización que es
estratégicamente muy importante porque
aquí hay desplegadas tropas del ejército
de eeuu y de hecho el presidente ha
pasado unos minutos con ellos les ha
intentado dar ánimos les ha dicho que su
misión es muy importante y que están
defendiendo la democracia en el mundo
esta ciudad también es importante porque
hasta aquí llegan los envíos de
armamento que luego son introducidos en
ucrania y también porque esta ciudad es
refugio de miles de refugiados
ucranianos que están huyendo de la
guerra y es por eso que va a ir en ha
querido trasladarse hasta aquí y ha
querido conocer de primera mano las
historias de los refugiados de hecho ha
estado unos breves minutos hablando con
algunos de ellos y sin duda este viaje
se puede leer en clave de ese apoyo que
está mostrando eeuu hacia polonia que
recordemos que es el país que por el que
han entrado un mayor número de
refugiados por aquí han pasado ya más de
dos millones de ucranianos y es por eso
que polonia ha tenido que activar todo
un sistema
de subsidios económicos también ha
dedicado más recursos al sistema
educativo y a los servicios sociales
para que los ucranianos puedan pasar
aquí unos meses o el tiempo que dure el
conflicto y por eso byd en este viaje
puede leerse en clave de apoyo a parte
de los fondos que se van a destinar
tanto para polonia como para los países
limítrofes que van a prestar apoyo a los
refugiados ucranianos también para
reconocer ese gran gesto que está
realizando polonia de recibir a
tantísimos miles de refugiados
ucranianos
llegamos al final de las noticias sigan
con france 24
[Música]